[Musik]
imposant ja das ist der mächtigste
wasserfall in ganz mitteleuropa und die
gegend rund um den bodensee
wie sieht der römerzeit als riesig sein
tonfall wisse und macht entstanden
die beiden columban und gallus und
später ordensfrau und klöster kennt die
gegend trägt und bis heute labertal frau
und mann
wo andere menschen mit ihren heilkraft
helfen und ihr könnt mir jetzt gut laufe
ruhige lose zur los märz vor sonderwegs
lernt leute kennen
da auch die it natur und trauer darüber
erfahren was vor rostocks basis und die
landschaft bis heute prägt das mal sind
die spirituelle werk aus purem in ihre
heimat erst später
der jugendforscher fuße schon recht
breit laden saubere vor der region am
grenzfluss zwischen der schweiz und
deutschland unter einer vor die
wichtigsten flüsse für europa von abos
nur kreisstraße ganze verkehr über stars
und laufen über theorie und zehn flüsse
und über den bodensee wo in der regel
richtet unverhüllten sind auf dem
wasserweg
kurz vor dieser hofe mache ich halt in
sankt katharina tal wurden dritter
jahrhundert kloster frauenberg
politisches auto schon fleck ein
die barocke viel aber hier gibt es noch
und johanniter komponistin helena
winkelmann abgemacht
[Musik]
lena winkelmann was verbindet sie mit
beim ort da der arktis mehrere sehr sehr
noch wenig hat die erste 2 auf um ihm
lieber in der sonne verbracht oder ein
paar hundert meter weiter oben ich
weitere kabine erstes solokonzert spielt
und der ruhm habe mir immer sehr viel
bedeutet das wenn ich das gefühl ich um
hey das ist nicht mal der tag nacht
verbringen und ich bin einfach der natur
amri ist unvergleichlich
wie viele auf der welt machen aber bis
jetzt ist für mich niemals wieder die
und einer starken naturkraft von wasser
spielt die rolle wenn sie komponieren
wenn sie musik machen
ich denke mir lieber generation wo
eigentlich zum ersten mal vielleicht für
künstler und umgesetzt hat musiker natur
niemals anfang und ein falle mich als
künstlerin die über jahrhunderte
weggehen und natur zum vorbild k und ich
rede jetzt eigentlich nicht von ihrer
direkt abbilden sondern ich rede ich
davor damals wenn man sich mit der
unglaubhaft oder natur drin ich möchte
verbinden künstlerisch damals mit großer
hochachtung und offenheit zu begegnen
und wir sind alle unter dem weg von der
natur hensler berechenbarer gemacht mit
welchen techniken dahlem und
verwirklicht natur immer noch sehr
wichtig und ich natürlich auch viele
sachen gesehen die komposition direkt
muss einfluss so zitiert zum beispiel
werde verkauft ganz ruhig ohne unterlass
und der gleichzeitig schaffen sie es
ändern sich immer an das wasser
gleichzeitig ist die verbindung von der
keller bis zum strom man trotzdem
irgendwo im blick hat das ist sehr
inspirierend für mich spiritualität was
ist das für sie es ist für mich immer
sehr seriös sein ziel vielleicht
einzigen mir fast so gigantisch also das
sagt viel ich bin eigentlich nicht
aufmerksam selber sich befassen und
entscheiden
und das so schwere entscheidung ich
hatte bis heute nicht als entweder oder
honnefelder
es ist einfach für mich die große frage
wie viel blut von meiner generation und
aus der vorhergehende generation da mir
mit dem glauben an sich nicht in dem
sinne schwierig ein traum er möchte der
fahrer versuchen die direkte erfahrung
und es gibt ja wunderschön sind wir mit
dem alter zeuge jugendwohnen riesigen
hus am zürichsee red und mit fragen über
gott glaube und ein lächelt arsenal- der
weiße alt und seit er glaube nicht
erwischt und das ist ich denke für
musiker sind praktische philosophie wenn
wir nicht wüssten den kommt das nicht
wir spielen musik hat für sie das
gespürt unglaubliche kraft ist es
letztlich musik wo ihre spiritualität
ist ich danke meinen hund zwischen hilft
das ja ich denke aber nicht alles nur um
musik alleine hätte losziehen
also ich hoffe und ganze umliegende
dörfer wo aber muss ich sehr bereichert
das ist man muss sich das flussbett und
es geht sehr viel zulauf auf der seite
[Musik]
bei hänssler mit viel technik bereiche
berg macht sagt elena winkel komisches
umso wichtiger als natur spüren ihre
kraft und von der natur zu lernen
[Musik]
meinberg für twitterte strom auf der wii
arena-boxstall ami
[Musik]
es steht immer noch fast so wie im
mittelalter dom etwa filmszene für die
spielfilme reformators ulrich zwingli
bereit mich interessiert jetzt besonders
sogar auf die toilette zurück seit dem
elften jahrhundert gibt es daran
klostergarten freitag
was macht der apothekerin
verschiedensten großes forschungsgebiet
becks eigentlich ich bin da im garten
zuständig für pflanzen unserer im
rittergarten forschungsgebiet ist
geschäftsjahr 2009 10 euro
und ja es ist wichtig dass man wirklich
eine historische pleite sache
dokumentiert und sogar zweifarbig für
strukturierte dem namen auch ganze
spannen die pflanzen ist nach der
schriftlichen überlieferungen und
österreichs jetzt warten sie zum glück
wieder vor den kämpfen
das ist kein scherz gebot bis dahin von
mir aus hätte es aber eine frau
heilpflanzen spannende wandel
durchgemacht
genau wie so viele vor den heilpflanzen
aus dem mittelmeergebiet und ich denke
zum bvs zum römischen bvs über
sporadisch und artischocken oder mal
eine wichtige bremse
das ist wie es der name sagt
ursprünglichste region mittelmeer
mittelmeer room for home es blätter
gepflückt und dann merken sie gar
wem das aber zu einfach
diese kosten nachvollziehbar
und das ist genau die spannend
kombination eigentlich bitterstoffe und
ätherische öl als aromatische will die
hintere breite wirkung auf den
menschlichen körper wo bisher viele
beschwerden sinnvoll sind
das macht man doch bloß und periode
thema casting tour allerdings die frühe
nach rosa mit textilien von
hochprozentigem schnaps nicht kränkte
sehr viel wie eine römische gehört oder
genau also mittelmeer geflossen
dank der klöster dass ich also römer
hinzu einige pflanzen mitgebracht kann
aber wirklich viel von denen man heute
als hoch ich würds kenneth oder als
arzneipflanze muss im mittelmeergebiet
sie in der sie mit der klostergründung
nach mitteleuropa und man innerhalb von
rohstahl um ein spezielles biotope
trainer schaffen also mitbewerbers klima
und kann damit mittelmeer pflanzen
überwintern im schnittbild fache mit als
ein organ ambri vor
die heilkunde das ist jetzt immer vorher
wie anerkannt ist das ist das
esoterische oder ist das heute der
medizin phytotherapie ist ja eigentlich
basis für die schulmedizin hypnotherapie
der pflanzenheilkunde als es nutze von
pflanzen als rohstoff für heilmittel das
war schon so alt wie die menschheit dass
man das schon immer buch hat die ältere
schriftliche medizinischem auch die
beziffert sich alle aufwand will das ist
der hauptrohstoff heilmittel hersteller
sieht antike das heißt man da eigentlich
wurzel vor der medizin genau genau
pharmakotherapie vor der
arzneimitteltherapie ich dass wir mal
was reißen noch bevor der voerder
kamille lavendel und herzsport baulöwe
schwarz heißt die pflanze und heil
rückte sind nicht nur wunderschön
sie schmeckt intensiv und auch dass ich
natürlich von der natur eso forscher der
aufenthalt im klostergarten wohltat und
wirkt beruhigend
[Musik]
wäre der gegend unterwegs ich sammle
trends erfahrung ganz konkret will
mischt ein dicker kanton wechselt und
diabetes legend ausland um in
abgelegenen ort rooney zum jüdischen
friedhof
[Musik]
es gibt mehrere jüdische friedhöfe auf
der höhe das ist ein halbes lambotte sie
ein katzensprung von der schweizer
grenze entfernt
deutsches youth erlaubt cbot sitze in
der schweiz nicht umhin viele in
deutschland gewohnt und die der schweiz
geschafft bis zu der zieht von
nationalsozialismus in sondernach der
disc ist der friedhof verwüstet und
synagogen in banger am boden zerstört
worden
wer es nicht schafft flüchte ich
verschlafe deportiert oder und braucht
worden
[Applaus]
klingeln
hallo hallo ich bin heute also ich bin
ja in st gallen aufgewachsen aber für
mich war das hier nochmal entdeckung so
diesem bodensee dem rhein und jetzt hier
im boden sehen dann sogar fische das war
schon immer eine spezielle region nicht
nur durch die klöster geprägt sondern
nachher eben auch durch kultur
insbesondere durch bildende künste wir
haben das otto dix haus wir haben einen
heckel wir haben so viele beispiel bin
jetzt gerade hier oben beim jüdischen
friedhof noch vorbei gekommen und es
soll hier eine lange tradition gegeben
eine sehr schöne geschichte eine
geschichte über integration und über
zusammenleben in einem dorf die juden
haben damals mit den wangen und zusammen
ja teilweise sogar unter einem dach
gelebt es gab hier eine synagoge ist
hier ein entsprechend auch jüdische
kultur und tja bis dann halt der
nationalsozialismus diese kultur
komplett natürlich zerstört hat aber 300
jahre ein zusammenleben das sieht man
noch heute noch anhand von architektur
und anderen dingen
ich hatte noch ein grad gesehen des
letzten juden eines arztes der hier
bestattet ist lebt diese geschichte noch
in der erinnerung hier weiter oder ist
es einfach unbedingt der sohn dieses
arztes von nathan wolf da gerd wolf
jetzt heute auch über 90 jahre alt lebt
noch hier an der hauptstraße er kann
erzählen wie eben sein vater hier auf
dem schiff noch gewunken hat als er
emigrierte in die schweiz
der dann nach dem krieg auch zurückkam
und der erste bürgermeister hier dann
wurde nach dem krieg der erste
bürgermeister und von dem er ist die
familie hier noch allgegenwärtig und
damit eben auch die geschichte
wir gehen auf eine andere geschichte zu
konstanz auf geht's legen wir ab der
e-card flöte meyer und sie ist
programmiert
das ist praktisch so kann die kilometer
polizei die gegen dich so riha
geschichten und geschichte das meiste
mit links und rechts liegen in weg führt
wie so viele wagen mit lauter ist
zentrum von der macht
aufgrund stand
[Musik]
wenn man unter der burg tore vaart ich
mir schon fast im hafen konstanz
begrüßte stadt am bodensee und im
mittelalter das zentrum von grösste
bistum nördlich von der alm
auf konstanz rau video viel zu europa
bald starten das ist außergewöhnlich
stadt grund stand sich im 2 weltkrieg
zerstört wurde
weil es aber soll die schweiz liegt da
hat es konzilstadt kunde sogar mit einer
papstwahl der autor und filmemacher luc
carl hätten dokumentarfilm über das
konzil von konstanz 3 ihn kenne ich sehr
gut wir sind vorne gewaltig nach oben es
klappte wie am schnürchen
tja ich schön wenn der body aussieht
ja krass wie bekannt
im 15 jahrhundert in europa drüber und
jedes vor verschiedene herrscher
unterstützt wurde
ein unmöglicher zustand der römisch
deutschen könig sigismund stritten
aufgrund stand sich platte siebziger von
einer viele versammeln könnte über vier
jahre erstreckt locken film über das
konzil von konstanz
das hat ein stoff in passiert wo er
stapelt gelegt für den stoff also sich
erstens sind ganz ganz spannender 2
es ist ein riesiger umbruchs politisch
religiös kulturellen ganz europa das ist
eine ganz andere ist besichtigt die
kongress das glaube ich eher nicht
lautet also die größte zusammenkunft von
florenz und der traurige der richter
darauf und impulslos damals entstanden
sind die sind gewaltig sie also kunst
das ist erst einmal dass man aber zum
beispiel musik für england im finale so
importiert wurde die knappen raum
freistadt ich kein dante england kommen
davor gar nicht zu kennen also sich ein
riesiger uns durch das ich aber nicht
nur religiös oder wirklich interessant
das ist ein polit in der ball kulturelle
liter sind da lässt sich am schnitt mit
nutzung der noch mal dass ich vor augen
führen was du da inszeniert test.de zu
oder der wohl zum konzil klima.de gang
ja
er habe damals oder verglüht sie es ganz
praktisch macht also all die kleinen
bayerischen bischöfe der schweizer
glühte buch eure kleinstes rein ich
wirklich das problem sie also ihr kind
zu hause so geschäft und kardinal sind
also nicht so wahnsinnig dass ein krieg
also meint dass ich habe mir überlegt
und die quelle hersteller das war doch
sehr aufwendig sind die rabattierung
zentralschweiz sind zwar mit lies mich
nicht groß ist oft sie hat und das habe
ich nicht ein warum ich alles an
begleitet wo nicht vor weil der
frauengruppe nicht weiter wie ein ist
der großzügige wichtig wenn die zutaten
die sind wahnsinnig schön gemacht also
nicht auch keine verantwortung liegt
wird das gerät und das sind im prinzip
nicht leiblichen bischofsgewand und dass
er wunderbar funktioniert und wirkung
von konzernchef de was bewirkt also das
primäre ziel und das jetzt erreicht dass
die türkei im poetry papst das ist
beendet wurde
man hätte abgesetzt und dann überquert
interviews wurde ich sage euch viele
sind erreicht wurde mittlerweile bieten
eine vormachen
weil leute macht war der bann gebrochen
dass ich eigentlich behalten und das ist
eigentlich schlimmer oder das wasser
richtig wenn es uns gar nicht sind die
bestimmt auch steuerliche wurde sind
vier stück sie eigentlich und das ist
eigentlich ja bis zum bis 1900 und
vertreibt genau das schon erreichte
inszeniert das unterhaltungs industrie
mit einem konzern verbogen sie heute
richtig spaß gemacht per notiert mit
leipzig stellte er sich zu unterhalten
das ist einfach ein riesen
uno-vollversammlung sie und der tcs raum
wird berichtet dass wir den fans konkret
und fasten ziehen und alles gab es heuer
huster prostitution
das gibt verschiedene zahlen also 700
slutwalks dagegen konnte juliane rosig
wobei man natürlich sagen dass im
mittelalter die prostitution ein anderer
stelle lag dass ich jetzt
auch die un sehen durfte und skandal das
ist verständlich sind wahrscheinlich
alle kreise sich da die händler
vertreten
das konzil hat spalte der römische villa
überwunden und spuren hinterließ hütt
liberia ich nun meter hoch die sahne
oder edel prostituierte erhöht
die beide männer wo sie drei sind winzig
und nackt es hat die hre aufgrund ziel
von bildhauer peter lenk
und sv konstanz
[Musik]
am wasserwerk sind im frühen mittelalter
auch rechtliche mission an bord gegen
arbon die columbus irland und seine
begleiter druckte gallus am boden sehen
sie sich dem trend der kolumbianer
schmitz auf italien
der prediger gallus ich bleibe und hat
als einsame ihre mitbürger
[Musik]
legendär seit der gal musik im jahr 612
dem schlüssel der steinacher vom
bodensee aus ihm ein großer wald- und
die einsamkeit große beute wildnis an
der steinach hüttig das mit der stadt st
ziege der gallushalle will dabei
begegnet er gegen der auftakt
persönliche sammlung für hätten die
feuerwehr ist großes brot geil ist das
einfach elegante oder das was auch immer
passiert sie das möchte vor allem müsse
wohl jedes jahren so massini zieht mit
wilder bei in alaska verbringt der david
mach ich mir sage ich immer flüchten
hallo da wie fit man endlich auch noch
mit sieben statt da wir haben natürlich
ein schönes licht sowie zum der
vorspringer so will die bayernlb aber
nun schnitt will wo sie zeigen mitbürger
müssten sie ja dafür sind eine familie
absolute lieblingsfarbe der ballon und
der musik und saks kenne also
mittlerweile schon fast 15 jahren sehr
spezieller mit lilith mit den jungen ja
auch so viele jahre mit dem wir schon
dreimal jetzt nachwuchs kadima und
danach viele jahre der absolute
lieblingsstadt louis gallois der
begegnung mit der bilderberg
ist ein absolut im mittelalter musiker
zeigten sich die papiere kein ganz
europa und das ist einfach zu der
begegnung
danke das ist das ist sicher kein
vertreter geschieht und dass die
begegnung offen speziell abgelaufen ist
dass sie so sein dass du den eleganten
bietet muss auf sie dann dass die gallus
und bayer sogar mit und veeam als
dunkles brot gibt
so etwas will ich da mit der eleganten
view schmückt und das und da sind zu
viert das ist unser ziel ist es
realistisch rational
vorstellungsvermögens was können sie
über beziehung zwischen mensch und bär
seite sich eine ganz spezielle show vor
du sicher vor jahren hätte war eine ganz
spezielle bedeutung haben
das müssen wir vorher malereien und
steigt kulturelle nachwies und bis heute
beschäftigt die bande mensch extrem und
polarisiert den operateur dass wir ende
sondern bezahle die situation darstellte
mensch physische verlage und fragen sich
betätigen
die klinik weil ich einfach den kopf
formen mensch sehr angesehene manager
baby und der jojo effekt da ist und alle
welt knuddeln und vorschule und die
gesetze sind sicher mit tanzte das gerät
das theater münchen so sehr fasziniert
david muss sparen und nasse fliehen
wollen ich komme wieder brandeten
einfachen antworten zu widerlegen
[Musik]
friedrich das alles eine große wildnis
sie die gallus sie morgens eine klausel
daher die gruppen hätten achte
jahrhundert das kloster gründete mit
seiner bibliothek das mächtige kloster
als kulturelles zentrum für ganz europa
werden
[Musik]
st gallen der name vor der stadt
erinnere bis heute van gaal muss der
klosterbezirk regal stadt sydney 208
unesco weltkultur her
die barock real lag bewahrt das
kulturelle erbe von der benediktiner
mönch
[Musik]
sie ist riesig der baukräne fast 100
meter lang
die bilder die komplette band da vorne
habe ich stundenlang nur getötete
dominik electric sie das sind die texte
bibel vorne sättigen gottesdienst und an
einer duftenden brief jetzt ein alter
bekannter der heutige bischof der markus
büchel kängurus frühere bischof markus
wenn wir da das taufbecken ist wasser in
word access gespielt im himmel im himmel
vor der grube gabst du dass du mal in
ich glaube da wir haben das wort
aufstieg auf worte wie und dafür öffnet
mir dürr vom himmel der welt martina
suchen aber tür bleibt offen
das ist heimat vom heiligen gallus wurde
anfangen mit der zeile es gibt ja das
gallus glücklich das wird gern mit der
gattin oder die alten wege
erkennst du immer so sagt mir erzählt
dass sechs originale von gallus nun
hätte überhaupt niemand ein damaliger
lautet das krach komplett auseinander
das ding
das hat es ausprobiert das stimmt nicht
mehr aber es hat nicht der schöne
klingen die ton wenn man sich das
erwartet das ist wie in einer spanischen
fans so tönt
ist der früh sagte ari vatanen der
kohlenbahn der leiter der chef der hätte
das flugzeug seine 12 aber ist es
wirklich original dann muss ich glaub's
und glaubt der geschichte aber es kann
immer bewiesen als bischof der tradition
vor dem gallus und von ob markus kloster
gründen was ist denn das für ein gefühl
ist gefühl dass man dankbar sich den
uni.de galuska website der st gallen
hält und mehr libyer und natürlich auch
noch stark vom geist vor dem kloster wo
das über jahrhunderte in ganz europa
technisch und portierung für die
bedeutung
[Applaus]
[Musik]
für die geschichte von sankt gallischen
frau ganz wichtig wo fast in
vergessenheit geraten ist die heilige
wie bora der versand gabe
rudolstadt wieder viele sankt manger
herzig klappt
morgen
die liga del play theologin und
seelsorgerin im bistum st sie lautet
schicht vor die bürger wieder aufleben
sicher ursprünglichen durchaus
hochwertig ist ich sehe wie heute nach
release von für sich gesucht und
spezielle nicht dass sie sich entschied
dort wo sich mögliche mode zu also das
heißt zwei jahre lang so schlosser hat
sie gelebt bis schlager worden ist 926
sie hat das fenster zur welt durch die
versorgt worden für ihren markt und das
fenster nach innen zur kirche deutlich
wenn der heilige meist eine das schon
schwierig zum verschlüsseln ihre
meetings oder ja das ist schon
wahnsinnig radikales von ja ermitteln
einsiedlerin sind sowohl erkennt und in
teilen von inklusion
ja das ist feinster nach ihnen machen
zeigen dass ich zu ihrem gewebe das jahr
bis ganz im ganzen wichtiger teil ist
ein batteriegesetz begabung und da hat
sich einer aber meist eine und eppstein
hat sie in der zeile natürlich stunde
gewartet und sie hat zwei einst so
weltoffen cover sie dann als beraterin
auch wichtig worden ist aber wir sind
natürlich die frau auf die idee sich im
ohr ist also auf jeden fall versuchen
die frau ein freiheits leben die frau
will eigentlich so komisch das fest und
ist das für mich ein emanzipatorischer
akt sich so in schließen slogan das ist
für eine frau von damals die einzige
möglichkeit unabhängig von einem das
leben oder unabhängig von
ordensoberen app dies sind es 34 moritz
epidemischen bliebe so schwimmer vor
ihrer hütte über rede was sie bewirkt ja
sie hatte staatsanwalt gerettet sie ich
bewahrerin das staatsorgan das heißt sie
hat der ungar in jedem im europäischen
raum stark sie sind hat überall so
überfällt sie hat das frühe und hat
schon rechtlich als jahr vergangen und
die heimaufsicht lust und hainan
gefangenen bibliothek zum teil auf die
insel reichenau zum teil in der flucht
burgtor in der nacht evakuiert und wo
die gefahr tatsächlich talks ist scheint
sich auch möglich evakuiert und
staatsapparat als die einzig sehr wohl
beschlossen hat sie die zeit sie bleibt
und das ist auch der grund warum sie in
ihrer zeit ein wurde der ungar
erschlagen worden ist sie später
heiliggesprochen worden wie es zu dem
hof
ja das ist als sich die erste offiziell
heiliggesprochene die frau von welt
es gibt frauen vorher wohl erich heilige
frauen sind aber es hat eine safari will
man das hat welche regeln und ja sie ist
der papst klemens heine gesprochen
worden
es geht den etat der professor im
stiftsarchiv und wie vor drin
standesgemäß laboranlage
das professur ist der große stolz vom
stiftsarchiv es ist du sie 200 jahre alt
und wertet wie einen schatz erspart
war das jetzt ein mega moment sehen wir
das buch voraus dass profis buch für das
anteilig gut wie bora detroit wurde ist
also ins männer durch in hilfe männer
durch womöglich bis ihm tritt am altar
und schreibt ich bin jetzt mental der
stadt kalenders wie bereit das vibrato
regloser paganinis inter renta wie borat
achim meyer auf der heyde erschlagen
worden
die paraden heiliggesprochen worden ist
also vielleicht noch 50 jahre später als
lied wo ihre namen denn da rund um sie
um ihr herr geschrieben zum beispiel
heinrich einander darüber einfach
gespürt aus dem wunsch seiner frau wenn
wir ganz nach sich so nach wie möglich
auch wie ein heiliger aber hat sie so
und somit das buch
[Musik]
oberhalb von der stadt st gallen fort so
bald der kanton appenzell ausserrhoden
die eigentlich bekannt für viele
alternative heilmethode doch er biss
mehr heiler als scherz sein
auf den einsamen hügel und die
abgelegene höfe hat sich viel als wiese
bebaut
er rief die tradition vor planzer grund
und heilkunst sowie therapiegerät lüth
dorn die leiter zum beispiel war zu
entfernen oder andere behandeln
früher hätte pure mutigste bäder
rechsteiner über 80 jahre alt er schafft
vor allem mit dem pendel
warum geht es nach dem appenzellerland
so viel geist heilerin heiler klassisch
das ist partie auch die überlegung dass
die ganz alte überlieferung dass
geistheiler das ist verlegung von der
urgroßmutter die hält also die fähigkeit
kann und alle alle der usa scharf wehrt
sich die einzelnen formen und größen
zwischen füssen und das erste offshore
bereich oder der hexe bezeichnet und ich
keine hütten und pendelt heute gar nicht
das teuflische zuläuft und drum denn die
leute gebettelt macht und gebettelt
kirchen akzeptiert und die hatten immer
natürlich von der urgroßmutter mit einer
gebete gegen aids und braun und brudes
stille aber so einfach kommt so wenige
wette sie stehen und die leute zum
normales spiel machen und ezb - pendler
wie wir das funktioniere handhebel dir
doch dann spielten die pendler wieder
die blockade lösen
und den lassen einfach schwingen und
fielen schon gar nicht zwischen zellen
arbeitet wie vor ein wechsel zu einer
sonnenkraft aber nicht wie ich jetzt
höre auf der alpe innerhalb steigt zum
sein dass sie auf über 1200 meter sind
mensch und vieh der naturkraft schutzlos
ausgesetzt
warum ruft center der alb sage das will
sie beschützen
[Musik]
so soll machen ja ja ja ja
ja ins paradies ist so ja aber man muss
erst rettete ja denn der jeden abend
absagen oder brother malus fallen also
selbst in höchste zeit also eine
besetzung auch harzer aber wenn sie es
wirklich einmal unheimlich strom ist
denn die betten so viel zum thema user
einfacher so also ohne dass sie den
richter führen im arbeite in kairo
geltende gemeinsames gebet die stoffe zu
viel
was bedeutete immer der absage es ist
schwer der schoss auf menschen und natur
und tier aber bitte sie scheinbar um
familie ist es wirklich ein gebet und
trompete unitas propagandazwecke quasi
wenn touristen verbrechen und die sagt
sie dass man schneller absetzen da ich
für stimmt für minute sagt zwischen dem
sie ihre macht und weil sie jetzt gerade
zieht
b
[Applaus]
[Musik]
a
ja
[Musik]
so wie ich vor über 300 york kapuziner
pater clemens geeignet oder anderen
erhält jedes tor und jeder berg
beschrieben
aber natürlich geheimnisvoll nicht alle
phänomen hat sich wissenschaftler klären
dort sind zwerge und geistes spiel hätte
auch die übersinnliche phänomene der
natur folgt beschrieben sind sage
entstanden
bemüht sind die lage in der region
verwurzelt und während vorsagen
erzählerinnen und erzähler mit aktueller
wir sind da ganz wichtigen achten da
natürlich gehen sagen
dagegen hatte ein drückt wenn man jetzt
sehen wir dass die dinge gerne groß und
wir sind jetzt nämlich in hugsweier
stimmt nämlich ein paar hundert jahre
und sie ist nicht größer als eine
5-jahres glücklich und sagte zur heißt
sachse weise für eine normale zwerge
völkle klebt und mit dem 12 wirkliches
ganzen hufe möglich
und sie ist ein deprimierter daran damit
geholfen aber eine wichtige sache
schließlich müsse der schatz bewacher
vom könig erhält edelstähle und gold
kreise in einer höhle in dem sinne floh
er in die oberhoheit draisinen und nicht
weißt was du da mama geschickt
lisa baum holen ex salzburger jetzt wo
sie denn wieder praxis zum wiederholten
male gesagt raum geben und auch die
chance und ich stets an die stände
richtlinie und hätte gesagt gott hier
von den menschen und ihre folgen
obama hat sich nicht etwa wie sich von
könig teilte ihre belohnung ist der
haken
darum hätte statt gold nur laub in
bündel kunde klar ist sie fertig war auf
der zwergenkönig hat sich bedroht
gefühlt und ihren lohn würde ich fordere
ist in einem anderen tag gegangen und
hätte dort gefunden wo mit dem beruf
sind und handwerker könig als angesagt
sind eine weile turrini und im selben
moment jetzt klebt stehe ganz oben und
ganz begraben
aber die fünf oder über gestand das
anzünden
vom selben augenblick anhalt mehr nötig
sein konzert gefolgt und mir sagt tom
sei es dauern bis speziell das weidlich
ist nämlich wächst sowie zu der sagt was
ich jetzt die natürliche korrektor für
das klima weltlich ja eigentlich das
herz ist es ganz klar dass ich dir sag
die natürliche klaric um rezitator
kritischste permafrost spürt immer noch
um vor allem vom blatte bödeli dass sie
versteht es geht doch natürlich jörg
reber 4 grad
was ist denn die idee vor der st für bis
zu erklären was mit natürliche erklärung
gibt auf anhieb sagen raum und zeit
entstanden weil immer als einheit viele
klubs klar was passiert oder wie
freiheit aber manchmal hat man will ich
dabei sein kann dass nur die hacken
maßregeln
[Musik]
ein werk für twitter unserem seien
historisch ist volker beck
[Musik]
für viele menschen hält mit geballter
heilen die wir krieg sondern auch schön
zum beispiel empfindet sie groß und
klänge der natur als heilsam
die sind aber ziemlich groß oberhalb von
wildhaus stoße auf deck lang weg er
gehört zur klangwelt toggenburg
das projekt wird musikkultur aus der
gegend zwischen dem säntis und
kurfürsten vermittle aber auch
überraschende verbindungen zu anderen
kulturen herstellt so musikkulturen in
europa afrika oder habe mit der
klangschale usa asien
[Musik]
zu der kultur vom toggenburg hörte
naturjodel ganze nur dümmliche form von
model
[Musik]
dass sie standen ließ ruhsamer büring
womit natur j luft wachsen ist und am
hackbrett peter roth musik herr und
mitbegründer von der klangwelt
toggenburg
[Musik]
ja
ist es ein zufall dass der naturjodel
kartons und ist jedem gebiete hey ich
denke vor allem de provence alpes cote
würde ich meine natur entstanden also
die melodie ohne worte besingt uhlmann
vielleicht gehört hat so wenn es
designer langweilig sich irgendwie an
gefangenen durch die summen oder unfähig
kräften
also es ist ganz praktisch im alltag so
eins ist auch klar
eigentlich ja musik berührt peter roth
ich dort erklang bergdorf erkennen wo
sie initiiert und musik und natur sowie
der busse sind wie startet sein machen
wie sehen sie das
ja für mich der naturjodel eigentliche
gebet das mantra sowie sie eine kultur
rund um werte geht die klang wo ja basis
total kultur und um das eint ist die
ganze welt eigentlich ein spirituell zu
phänomen also gönnen klangschale wer
glaubt die ja eine kultur immer wenn dir
wenn seit der grenze zwischen dem die
sie tun ihren sitz zwischen dem
materielle und geistige spirituelle hat
immer wieder klang instrument und stimme
also der gong meditieren oder aber sie
ein normales uhr bevor der ton hebe
gerät oder wie ich ausgegangen
gerade hat er sein rad habe ja das
könnte doch mal probieren und ja gerne
probieren denn man muss da muss man
schauen was man noten hause sagt oder
bequem ich stehe nicht also denn
probieren mal zwei tönen
wir singen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
dazu
[Musik]
ja
schön
noch im alpstein und im toggenburg bin
jetzt in rapperswil am zürichsee hoch
[Musik]
fotos love is letzte stück einmal wieder
auf dem jakobsweg
das ist einfach ein weg sondern als
ganzes netz von pilgerweg nach santiago
de compostela in spanien zum grab vom
heiligen jakobus führe der weg jetzt
über der etzel basti zu vereinzelten
mittelalter eigentlich der wichtigste
daten auf dem jakobsweg in der schweiz
[Applaus]
[Musik]
vorab muss will führt der pilgerweg über
der horde stück wo erst vor 20 jahren
erbaut worden ist
vermehrte äpfel und den gott steilufer
richtig etwas zu der kapelle st meinrad
steinberg ich im winter jahrhundert der
meinrad gewandert und hat auf der
passhöhe der zelle baut hütte start der
kampagne spiritueller weg bin ihm kommt
und spitzahorn
im mittelpunkt stehen manager und
traditionen vor der heilkunst einige vor
der bedeutendsten figuren vorteil kunst
überhaupt ich glaube geboren
der querdenker visionär und arzt
paracelsus der paracelsus entzieht vor
der reformation wird im 16 jahrhundert
er hat sagte der damalige schulmedizin
stellt und teil kreft von der natur
genutzt
ein visionär das letzte stück vom bag
bonita bruder gerold zenoni vom kloster
einsiedeln
er beschäftigt sich seit jahren mit dem
paracelsus sicher schöner wohnen ja
selbst dafür dass grund jetzt klebt
hinter den brawngp-piloten ja und diese
konstruktion und nadja wurde gerold sie
interessieren sich sehr für die
theologische sitte von paracelsus dass
sie noch nicht mal alle schichten
offenbar veröffentlichte damals
sensation für was ich somit pro ist in
der theologische schriftlich sehr der
mensch vorkommen dass sie sich nicht
theologie wo jetzt das jenseits verträgt
nicht völlig neu
aber er wird eigentlich als meinte da
auf der raum fast zum paradies wird
wartet unter anderem und das vertrauen
sie nicht unbedingt zum thema selbst im
hcs und immer so auf wesentliches man
das land wo man mit der lippe dritte der
paracelsus la petite vor der reformation
i sharif lust vor der reformatoren wie
verlosen schief lust auf die ganzen
eigene linie wird ich sagen biografie
seit mitentscheider ob jetzt der
paracelsus
definiert physik oder über katholische
sieg tatsache ist dass er eine richtige
kritisch gegenüber gestanden ist aber am
schluss hätte sich ausdrücklich
katholische abartige und damit
erheblichen masse wohl auch im tod von
cattolica falle dass die zelle klasse
werde die masse also der paracelsus auch
in der theologie wieder ein querdenker
durchaus noch hat eigentlich fast nicht
bis an das erwartete vor dem quartett
aus dem hochtal vor einsiedler
einsiedler schließt sich der kreis für
die geschichte von paracelsus und die
geschichte von der heilkraft
ins kloster einsiedeln bedeutende
schweizer wallfahrtsort mit seiner
schwarzen madonna und der boden geholt
zehn tieren offizielle ich leider
und 21
nicht so klar da glaubt verdutzt
ich biete schwarze madonna ist ziel für
viele gläubige frauen und männer aus der
schweiz und aus der ganzen welt sogar
industrieland krache mitregiere drohne
sie alle bietet madonna um hilfe den rot
oder heilig verschmerzen
was ich denn die heilen die wäre krieg
vor der madonna vor der schwarzen
madonna nach dem verständnis und der
katholische viele der muttergottes
downey debatte sondern sie ich
vermittlerin verteidiger wo daher vorher
braucht wartet zu jesus christus uns
geht das alter lehrt was heißt ab heute
gottes war die niere und blieben es hat
er wirklich
ich habe in letzter zeit motiv darf
lassen manager bank hat wenn man das
nokia werk an
glauben sie persönlich dass die
möglichkeit wahr sind
es geht ja nicht nur um heiliger sondern
neue kritik muss oder schwierige
situation es gibt zum beispiel das bild
wo der bahnübergang zeigt wenn es schon
mit knapper not dem heranbrausenden zug
das sind situationen und ideen situation
ein doofer partie lied ganz spontan sich
ein motto das einsiedler gewandet und
sind der erde wurde hatte sie ja das
bild also im stadtgarten also glaube
hilft glauben halt gilt das bis heute
zweifellos verbleiben würde positiven
aspekt im labor oder manche meiner
meinung nach
danke für ihre psyche und das anders die
schwarze madonna vor einsiedler wo
heilig vermittelt der arzt paracelsus
500 jahr gefragt wie medizin kann heilen
und natur und klein wo heilsame wirkung
profis management das alles sind
entdeckung auf ist ein spiritueller weg
und der niedrig sich selber auf den weg
zu machen
[Musik]